[Music]
unless you are watching this video from
Syria it's fair to say that no matter
how bad the situation in your country
Venezuela is doing worse as of 2015 they
are experiencing more inflation than any
other country in the entire world
furthermore their capital Caracas is
currently ranked as being the world's
most violent city beating out other
famously violent cities in both Mexico
and Colombia something as simple as
buying toilet paper has also become
practically impossible in Venezuela and
scarcity has become a norm in
supermarkets other products such as
condoms have to be bought and sold on
the black market and all of this is
happening in a country with the world's
largest oil reserves in fact it wasn't
so long ago that Venezuela was the
richest country in the whole of South
America but today over half their
population lives in poverty so the big
question is how did they end up there
how did the government destroy the
economy in such a short amount of time
today we're gonna tell you that story
there will be variant revolution the
first character in our story is Hugo
Chavez the father of modern-day
Venezuela or should we say the
Bolivarian Republic of Venezuela he
became president after a landslide
victory in 1999 his campaign was based
on the promise of equality and poverty
reduction a policy that he called 21st
century socialism one of his first
policies was called the system for the
democratization of jobs this was meant
to be implemented in the pdvsa the state
company that extracts Venezuela's oil
and don't forget now that we're talking
about a country that has bigger oil
reserves than Saudi Arabia dvb-s a spy
role has more than doubled to a hundred
and fifteen thousand employees since
Chavez took office in 1999 and that has
recent tenfold since 2006 234 billion
u.s. dollars this was pretty big news
considering the PDVSA is the largest
company in South America nevertheless
Venezuela kept producing the same number
of barrels per year this means that the
staff increase had nothing to do with
corporate reasons but rather political
ones
in fact this job democratization was a
way to employ all of the unemployed
Venezuelans the same thing happened in
the government during the Chavez's
administration public spending tripled
[Music]
this meant more government workers and
more social programs of an ever before
however none of this was a problem as
long as the oil exports kept paying the
bills
in fact Chavez cut poverty in half
despite being an oil-rich country before
Shabbos 60% of the population lived in
poverty ten years after Shabbos only 30%
did despite a versus rhetoric that
capitalist countries were trying to
destroy the revolution no one would
reject Venezuela's oil even Nicolas
Sarkozy france's conservative presidents
over the time was complementing
Venezuela's democracy I'm glad about
Venezuelan elections with their strong
turnout the Tros once again the vitality
of democracy in Venezuela - all of these
policies we must add the famous fair
obviously this literally means
expropriate this expropriation being the
taking away of private property from its
owner savez was no fan of private
businesses and it was not uncommon for
him to visit a city and go around
declaring the various businesses be
nationalized this would include all
sorts of businesses including things
like small shops all of this ended up
with Venezuela having an economy if it
was fully dependent on its oil by 2012
Brent barrels were 95 percent of
Venezuela's exports we should also note
it at pdvsa at higher costs than any
other oil company and this was largely
because of the staff increases
nonetheless as long as the oil price
remains high enough to cover the
production costs Venezuela kept making
oil and everyone was happy but just hold
on a minute because this is where things
turn sour in 2014 oil prices fell and
Venezuela was the first country to feel
the effects of this for their profit per
barrel shrank more and more every single
day
[Music]
nicolas maduro SEDOL up now by the time
the oil crisis started Hugo Chavez had
already passed away and his successor
was a guy named Nicolas Maduro really to
see you whistles I was prob er look at
me funny then flew over my hand and I
could feel the spirit of Shabbos
blessing Jacob although the whole
darkness you know this is not a joke nor
is it a quote taken out of context
Maduro found himself the head of a
country that wasn't making enough money
from its only export and Maduro
and wages to pay then on top of all this
we have the famous now because of all
that expropriating that was going on
we've been left with a Venezuela that
has no private companies so even if he
decided to raise taxes there's no one
left to pay them and this is when Maduro
made the most irresponsible decision
that any political leader can make he
decided to print money having devalued
the Venezuelan currency the believer
inflation skyrocketed here's an example
of how bad this was imagine you're
sitting in a bar in Caracas in July of
okay Emily cost you around 50 bolivars
then you go back to the same bar in
Caracas in September and that same beer
would cost you 100 bolivars this has
been happening in Venezuela consistently
for the last of three years
[Music]
obviously this had the effect of
destroying all of the poverty reduction
measures that Shem has it implements it
oh and believe me it gets worse from
here just when things were looking
really terrible madero decided to
demonstrate just how much worse they can
get law implemental later the youtubes
to finish with the price increases will
be the creation of the maximum sales
price so much there enter ponies
according to majora the hyperinflation
was caused by those evil capitalists who
wanted to destroy Venezuela so the
logical solution of course was to fight
them so you're probably wondering right
now what exactly the outcome of all of
this is well this time let's imagine
that you own a butcher's shop in the
beautiful city of Meraki do you buy meat
from a Colombian farmer and you pay with
the US dollars for example let's say
that a pound of beef costs you $10 the
venezuelan central bank has an official
exchange rate of 10 bolivars to 1 US
dollar burn no one's gonna sell your
dollars in that price because the market
price is way higher this means that if
you want to buy beef from your Colombian
producer you're going to have to pay the
price set by the market this is the
equivalent of 10000 bolivars per 10
dollars
[Music]
all right fine but then you go back to
your shop and you want to sell this
pound of beep that you bought but then
you find out that the government has set
a maximum sale price of a thousand
bolivars which is ten times less than
what you paid so now you've got two
options you can one close up your shop
or to sell your meat on the black market
now some of you might be wondering why
do they have to buy foreign li why can't
they just buy meat that was made inside
Venezuela the answer is that whatever
product you buy it's going to require
something that is made outside of the
country that you bought the product in
for example if you want to grow wheat
you're going to need a tractor which is
manufactured somewhere else and you
might find that even the seeds or the
fertilizer are also made in a different
country one way or another there is no
country on earth that is capable of
producing all that they consume not even
the United States oh and don't forget
now that Venezuela based their entire
economy on the export of oil and today
still that's not going so well
Venezuelan oil has become so expensive
that they'd rather buy it from external
sources than even use their own oil
Beadie BSA has launched one of its
largest oil tenders ever seeking to buy
some eight million barrels of us or
Nigerian light crude for delivery from
April through June as I mentioned
previously Venezuelan oil is really
expensive to produce and it turns out
that they just rather buy from other
countries than use their own oil
meanwhile shops cannot import goods this
is leading to a scarcity of toilet paper
and has even led to situations where
people have stabbed each other over a
small piece of bread
so now that we've given you the rundown
on Venezuela we'd love to know what you
think do you think Maduro will be able
to pull his country out of collapse do
you see there's an alternative for him
to pursue we'd love to know your opinion
just let us know in the comments below
and do not forget that we upload brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday and
if you want to get notified about those
please do subscribe to this channel also
if you enjoyed this video please do hit
that thumbs up button below and I'll see
you next time